oh my gosh we are back we are back we
are back it is full lobokoff season it
is full training camp we are fully in
left go show mode umber and left go here
to get it going
got an awesome interview coming up in
just a few minutes with Jordy Nelson got
another great interview coming up later
on with Kyle Rudolph
we got NFL good guys we got quarterback
dancing list at a wedding
we have whoa big offseason and I went
into a float tank this weekend he had
about that at the end and you've been
floating ever since I'm floating man
like a butterfly stinging like a bee but
I think what's really cool is - I just
did a check I did not even announce this
on the podcast yet but I put it out on
Friday on the Internet's who wants to
join the left go Football gridiron
league and the people came out in force
let's [ __ ] go League the lfg we are
currently at at 800 I love it 800 people
have signed up to play in the let's
[ __ ] go League let's get into four
four digit territory let's go last year
we had 396 we have 800 right now which
is incredible William Ezell the Saints
fan has already reached out to some of
the people that have said yes I'll be a
commissioner we are going to make the
cutoff Tuesday what is today's date
Tuesday July 30th at 5 p.m. at 5 p.m.
I'm putting a hard line in the sand if
you hear this after the fact then you
missed out bro I'm sorry so so check out
social it's on Twitter right now and
then again if you're filling out the
forms you'll have a Twitter and
Instagram it's all good but William
Ezell is the guy I will put out the
links one more time on Tuesday morning
but we are shutting it down Tuesday at
5:00 p.m. however many people we get is
what we're gonna do
I have no idea how we're gonna run 7080
leagues but also what we're gonna do
Thursday August 22nd is going to be the
draft night because well last year we
let all the commissioners talk to all
their people and figure out the best
time to draft it's just too many moving
parts right we are gonna sign everybody
up Thursday August 22nd we are going to
be in Vegas that's what I wanted to get
and so I'm gonna you know we have our
studios in Vegas I'm gonna do the draft
like Thursday at 8 o'clock Eastern is
going to be the drafts of five o'clock
West Coast time but I'm gonna be doing
the draft live we're gonna do everybody
and what I really want to do is take
videos make them as creative as and
funny as possible of how you're drafting
it could be outfit it could be location
you could be like having like a team of
70 people of toddlers picking your team
for you but I really want you on
Instagram stories or on Twitter tagging
the left coast show and sending how
you're drafting cuz I'm gonna be in
Vegas with all the like cool like what's
it called the sports book behind yeah
sports book will be behind me but I'm
thinking Thursday August 22nd will be
the draft I'm working with ezel right
now it's looking like a half point PPR
I don't want kickers I mean we talked
about what the fantasy footballers I
think we go through with it
okay but I'm thinking right now the
playoffs might be 13 and 14 with a Grand
Championship on 15 and that's like the
winner of the winners and winner or the
winners is week 15 I just I'm always
tired of week 16 happening and Patrick
mahomes isn't playing right there's some
team that's locked up everything and so
let's let's fix this [ __ ] and not do
kickers and have the championship in
week 15 when I have never seen a team
rest people in week 15 yeah you'd have
to some crazy things would have to
happen for you it has to be like a 50/50
nano team or 40 nano - in the worst
division possible right
so I just I'm tired of week 16 defense
like determining championships but the
league is coming together mm-hmm so I
think August 22nd and then the cutoff
will be Tuesday July 30th at 5 at 5:00
and if you're looking for creative ways
to do your draft as left go mentioned
extra points if all the guys in your
league are in a sensory deprivation tank
and they're all filling there with their
laptops that will be incredible I don't
know how you're gonna draft I'm just
saying the extra points if you can pull
that off I'm also thinking and Inga I'm
curious what you think I had a guy reach
out to my DMS and say man we need a bet
on that bears Eagles game hmm I have
decided and I'm curious what your
thoughts are I wanna bet against a fan
whoever the Eagles are playing that week
oh that's just that's your gimmick
that's just one of my things I do sure
so if they play the Giants
I want one Giants fan I want like $100
venmo bet don't make the bet if you
can't afford $100 if we play the Colts I
want a Colts fan do we need to like wink
wink you venmo it to someone on a barge
in the you know in the Caribbean and
they venmo it back to you so it's all
kind of kosher but then you know what we
could do maybe there's also something
that you have to do for me and that I
have to do for you so that it's really
like I did something for the hundred
dollars yeah that like if they want you
to like leave an outgoing voicemail per
you know like some special occasion
leave a voicemail for someone or I want
them to record something like really
embarrassing for the podcast
hmm you know so it's it's worked labor
getting a Giants fan to admit like that
the Eagles are the greatest team in the
NFC East some like that yeah yeah and
then maybe they get a shout out on the
podcast we're like I hold up a picture
of them and say everybody should follow
this person they're really great screw
my life and would you be you'd be you be
betting on the Eagles right I don't even
know if I want it against the spread I
kind of want money let me straight up
yeah because we're gonna be doing so
many gambling stuff during the show
normally sure that I want that one to be
more pride just the Eagles win so yeah
so if the Eagles go thirteen and three
then you will thirteen and three on the
air that's what I say you're betting on
your team I like this yeah well well you
know what we'll figure it out yeah but I
want to bet against people every week I
want them to be in the action too
okay I think it'll be good so I have a
tweet right now it's starting to bust a
little bit we did it last year I did it
again this year the NFL good guys and
what I kind of did was I just sat with
my notebook
went through every team in the NFL and I
tried to find those charitable
storylines that have maybe faded away
that people forgot about we're about to
start talking about holdouts and roster
cuts but I think it's important you know
and and off the field issues to remind
everybody of all the good [ __ ] that
happens every year and for me it's it's
fun because I forget about some of these
stories you know I forget about Kenny
Moore paying for a funeral and then also
saving a dog's life oh right right you
we forget about these but they were a
huge deal for 24 hours you should steal
I'm so impressed at what I've seen with
Anthony Lynn and going to Tanzania and
building a school for 300 kids and then
I read more today and he talks about
this is not just a one-time thing I'm
going to Tanzania every summer for the
foreseeable future amazing that just
makes you feel so good like when you
when we start questioning Anthony Lin's
offensive strategies midway through the
year just to know that like as soon as
the season's over he's going to like a
country that needs his help like that
well even the little ones like I see
who's the runner Aaron Jones just
started pushing an old lady at an
airport because nobody was around and
then I think about myself like I would
see an old lady at the airport being
like hello and I'm like man it sucks for
her Aaron Jones is just pushing without
even asking or like telling people he's
just doing it like from the big things
like going halfway across the world to
the little things of like the decency in
an airport the things I would never do I
just appreciate those stories so much it
makes me feel happy
yeah and for these celebrities that do
it so if you pushed a woman that needed
it in the airport that's a nice thing it
doesn't devalue that but it but a famous
guy he must in the back of his head know
that someone might catch this and put it
up on Instagram so it's only a win for
him right so you might as well do it if
you're famous right just just give 30
seconds of your time someone might put
it on Instagram yeah you're seen as a
great guy and then at the absolute worst
a bunch of people see it and they go hey
maybe I'll do that too but you know
what's awesome aaron jones didn't know
that he was photographed until after he
got off his flight that's the banner so
four hours the
building and but what I love is is that
you can do it for attention or you could
avoid it the attention and the attention
finds you because that's how good deeds
work right like everyone's talking about
how Zeke's holding out Zeke paid a
funeral for a kid in st. Louis that got
shot by a stray bullet and he was not
the one that told the media the kid's
mom did mm-hmm and so you know see just
wants the money he just wants the
attention but then he goes and does that
and doesn't seek it mm-hm and that's
when it hits me even harder is sure the
Saints you know was working with the
media to kind of go and and build this
wheelchair ramp but then I see like this
kid Dre that really really surprised me
that I wanted to spotlight more because
look I'm learning about some of these
good stuff too I don't have all these
saves you know I'm going through Google
and I'm trying to find it so when I see
about this kid Dre who was a 5th round
pick by the San Francisco 49ers
the 49ers didn't even know about this
story but it comes out after he was
drafted that Dre Greenlaw was in college
and the father of a daughter that went
to a college party something was slipped
into her drink
she was cornered and this kid as a
freshman on the Arkansas football team
who knew this girl slightly not even a
lot got in the way of this other person
stopped it kind of pushed him out the
way sent him home and made sure that
this girl got home safe and the dad put
out a Twitter thread saying I've never
told the story he's never told the story
I just want Niners fans to know they got
a good one this happened like four years
ago Ingeborg and like if I was in a job
interview in the NFL and someone wanted
to say what's your character I would
have been like well there's one time my
freshman year the fact that it never
even came out until after he was drafted
they're not even doing it for attention
sometimes yeah you know like sometimes
it's photo ops but sometimes it's just
the really good [ __ ] and I
think a lot of times we get caught up in
like the three or four guys that get
arrested and instead of like the three
or four guys that are that are like Greg
Olson or Thomas
mr. Larry Fitzgerald or Chris Long like
we know about those guys but I've never
heard of dray Greenlaw it's classic
confirmation bias because if you read
three or four headlines that go beyond
the sports website world that there have
been some arrests right if something
horrible happens with domestic violence
it's gonna go way beyond just bleacher
report.com it's gonna go to a lot of
arrests it might just be money shelving
Gordon holding out Zeke holding out
Antonio Brown you go oh these guys are
greedy right so you you read three or
four of those and you just ascribe that
to the entire population of NFL guys but
if you read 30 different stories in a
row of them being a good guy people have
this ability to say it's just 30 good
guys out of hundreds and hundreds in
this one league it's like no no if
you're gonna you're gonna have it both
ways if you want to take three or four
anecdotes and make that about the entire
NFL then you should take these good guys
ones too and make bait there's a lot of
good guys in the NFL and I think for me
I think long and hard about well what
kind of NFL shell is a left go show
because I think about that cuz I want to
stay true like a true north and I would
say that featuring the good characters
in the NFL and then doing fun [ __ ] like
ranking them in terms of how they would
dance at a wedding like that's I know it
sounds like a really weird subset of the
NFL but that's where I want to be yeah
you know what I mean because I everyone
can break down salary cap implications
everyone can break down all 22 and and
the importance of offensive line and is
this going to be the year of play-action
we can all have those conversations I
just think there's this white space of
talking about character and we do it in
every other league and I just think it's
about time we do it for the NFL there's
a lot of room in media for a lot of
different kinds of people Stephen a does
what Stephen is right Darren Revell does
what their and Ravel does love him or
hate him that's what they do they have
their mark on their niche and you know
you want it you want to find out what
people aren't doing and what you're
excited about talking about yes so I did
put out my dance circle wedding rankings
it's another threat on my Twitter if you
want to check it out I'll give you my
top five my bottom five and then Ingmar
you can poke holes because I don't even
know if you've seen this yet I'm taking
a look now number one and I'll do a
little description so it explains it
number one is Baker Mayfield part of
what I think makes a great dance circle
a little bit of the unexpected hmm I had
Cam Newton at 3:00 deshaun Watson at
2:00 Fitzpatrick at 4:00 Jamis at 5:00
give you a quick reasoning Cam Newton
there's very high expectations so we're
excited to see Cam Newton in the dance
circle but I always think we're gonna be
a little underwhelmed because we're
expecting something crazy interesting
deshaun Watson I watched him do a dance
circle in Clemson and I posted the video
and he was so smooth with it and I also
think that we expect to Shawn to be a
little bit quieter that when he nails it
in the dance circle it takes it to the
top but Baker is the perfect mix where
we expect but were always still
surprised and when you watch the dance
circle video it had the most important
aspects people were calling him which
means they know at the end he's going
who's next which means he's keeping the
dance circle alive being an improviser
you have to be generous and give to the
next partner and I think it's important
in these videos to see when you're when
they're the circle's a little quiet and
then when they're done it's a totally
different circle that's what he did
mm-hmm
fitzpatrick if he hits one move the
place blows up explodes and the true
thing is is you might not have a dance
circle if ryan fitzpatrick hits a split
if I thought if Ryan Fitzpatrick had a
split or even a template going home yeah
we're gonna be attempts we're going home
it's over Jameis is great the reason I
had him higher than most people is he's
never gonna not be afraid and he might
get in a few times to get other people
evolved so he's keeping that circle
alive mm-hmm my bottom five cousins his
last Andy Dalton I found a video of him
doing the chicken dance
and it's just really embarrassing it at
one point no one was doing the tenon and
it like the thing with him and so he
just stood there and gave two thumbs up
and as soon as I saw that I said I can't
have this guy anywhere near it drew
brees i found a clip of them in the
locker room where he's dancing
drew brees is like the dad that
one new move and everyone laughs but
what put him at the the bottom of the
list is I hear cam Jordan if you listen
to the clip that I posted 30 seconds in
he walks in and cam Jordan goes who let
him dance and when I heard that's a
great quote yeah I went he gotta be
towards the bottom Flacco is too stiff
and and Tom Brady it's Tom Brady's right
there with Brees where they're dancing
and they think that everyone is super
happy that they're dancing but they're
really going alright like six more
seconds and then like let's get somebody
else in there what is the optimal amount
of time in the wedding circle that
you're supposed to spend because you
don't want to be there for five-second
25 seconds that's I was gonna say more
like 15 the the elites can give you 25
okay if you have enough material to
sustain five seconds Akers giving you a
solid 25 Deshawn cam what Cam Newton
they're giving you us Jameis might go 50
mm-hmm that's the problem is he might go
too long but Cousins is gonna give you
like one move for four and then he's
like I gotta get out of here that's the
thing too in the wedding circle when you
see someone come in literally just like
shake their hips for three seconds and
then scamper back to the side all
sheepishly it's like you didn't even
bother like come on at least you should
be three or four moves deep did you see
any names that were surprisingly high
surprisingly low or anything to talk
about
as you know I'm much more into the
criteria these because you could go in a
lot of different directions but for me
number one you want someone that has a
signature move yes right cam has the dab
right yes and Aaron Rodgers he could
always discount double check it
absolutely right if you were at a
wedding and Aaron Rodgers did a couple
of little cool moves did a little disco
something and then ended it on the
discount double check people would lose
their money yes so if they had him more
towards the middle because Rodgers is
also one of the too-cool-for-school guys
that he he and Matt Ryan and Jimmy G I
have and true Biscay I have that being
great in the circle laugh guys that when
someone's going they're like oh yeah
but when it points to them their first
reaction is I'm good and and and they
have a role like like Eli is and I gotta
admit something I forgot to allow the
list this was not malicious you know you
forgot people like the constant
disrespect to eat
needs to stop and I'm like bro I just
forgot you did have Daniel Jones at
seventh though who's kidding no I didn't
even put Daniel Jones on there did I no
no I'm just kidding oh yeah no no yes
but it's like Russell Wilson is about
seven or eight because he dances but
he'll give you the 15 seconds and then
he'll be on the outside keeping rhythm
mm-hmm and like ready to go in but like
no one's asking for it so he's an
elite-level circle guy but not an
elite-level
dancer guy what are your feelings on you
know like one person goes in the middle
they do a thing that come out second
person goes in the middle they do their
thing they come out then a couple goes
into the middle Russell Wilson and Ciara
right she can bust a move as well as
anyone out there right the two of them
if they had like worked something out a
little routine that I was the dip and a
lift and a spin people going nuts for
that had me insane so it you know I
think that's a value-add maybe like Tom
Brady with Giselle in the middle of the
floor that could be a little more value
than I think you're giving him credit
for
I had Lamar Jackson at 17 people were
very surprised I can move but I looked
every touchdown he does the Kodak Bop
it's the only dance move he does I even
found a video in college where he was
interviewed and they said what your
celebration gonna be he goes oh I only
do the Kodak pop I'm glad that you have
a move but your move needs to change
based on the location you're doing a
home team move but if you go to someone
else's party there but they might not
know the Kodak pop you might need some
variety and variety is very important I
think this is a little unfair of you to
judge his wedding dancing based on
exclusively his touchdown dancing not a
great move and it's the only move he
does I'm just saying like if someone
asked you to make a bunch of burgers and
hotdogs for a barbecue and then you you
judge their five-star cooking based on
the burgers that they made it's like no
no they were asked to do a specific
thing here right they they might have a
whole bunch more like chamber this would
be my part of my criteria if you score a
touchdown you do your best move that's
your moment to shine
you don't think I save it for what I
watched I wa I watched an interview
where Derek Carr said he can do a moon
dance or moonwalk
but he's only doing it publicly until he
scores a touchdown like a running
touchdown I don't think he's gotten it
yet hmm
so people save up you know what I mean
that's try have seen I know Travis Kelce
can dance after touchdown we've seen it
in the end zone yeah we see that one guy
on the Panthers it's always doing that
chicken head [ __ ] like yes so it was
it's so much fun to like find videos of
these guys dancing I was very and I hear
stories of josh al and i asked some guys
derrick karr the video of him dancing in
that is really great a lot of people
sent me the video of Eli Manning no
Dells commercial right as proof that Eli
can dance like that's not proof of
anything
proof of editing O'Dell
so yeah you're right commercials cannot
be trusted right because harnesses the
editing and CGI and we know and we don't
know what is very serious I can
appreciate that can I just throw
something at you because your your
bottom five has Brady Flacco Brees
Dalton cousins and the the running theme
there is that they're gonna be a little
too stiff right and they're they're not
gonna really ham it up now I'm just
thinking back to all the weddings that
I've been to in my life where you're on
the shuttle bus back to the hotel or
you're you know you're driving back to
your hotel whatever what's everyone
talking about in the room is the most
awkward moment of the night right what's
the thing that you remember five years
later from this wedding is oh that it
really insanely awkward six foot nine
guy that like kind of did the worm but
then it fell apart and he he said
chauvelin which one of these might
surprise me joe flacco I think you're
right I think if Joe flex went out there
I think you nailed it he was the one
guys I'm filling out where I'm like
Flacco might do something [ __ ] that's
what I'm sayin because I agree with he's
built up so much equity in our brains as
he's a statue right there because I look
at these and they're all Colin responses
Dalton would get nervous breeze would do
what everyone else is doing Brady is
just gonna jump around and do this hand
motion thing that he does I don't know
about foals
Rivers is too busy watching all the kids
at the table but I you know what if
there's one guy that would [ __ ] up my
rankings it's Joe Flacco yeah because if
Joe Flacco did that thing where like he
spins on the ground and then ends in a
poem like soccer goal celebration like
that's why I put Fitzpatrick there
because like fitzpatrick would jump in
there in the top five like he would do
it but if Flacco did it the walls are
coming down that's what I'm saying like
you can't even hold the rest of the
wedding party does everybody send
everyone home he licks his like universe
gets it done but everybody was sending
me the Odell Beckham Eli thing and then
a CL epidemic struck the Giants you know
Corey Coleman goes down
sterling Shepherd apparently breaks his
thumb probably will not be a season long
injury though but he have to imagine a
thumb injury for a wide receiver not
great and then Golden Tate is now facing
a four-game suspension and I'm gonna be
honest I had people DMing me the day
before saying Shh I hear Golden Tate
suspension is coming so now I have to
take those dm's a little bit more
seriously and right I'm so props to the
33% that we're sending me that than the
inside info but they're starting wide
receivers for the Giants or Cody Latimer
darius latent Benny Fowler like and I'm
wondering is this about to be the curse
of the Beckham Beano
oh I like this not the Bambino yeah when
the Red Sox got rid of Babe Ruth there
was this collapse that they had been
this proud organization with five World
Series titles and then it went about a
century as you're very well aware and
well aware of the Red Sox not winning
the Giants have four Super Bowl trophies
Beckham has now been traded to Cleveland
and it seems almost too ironic that all
of the receivers the same position he
left that position is now collapsing and
I'm just wondering are the Giants about
to feel a curse at the wide receiver
position this is I you've come to the
right place
as someone that's been on the mister Red
Sox fan right mr. Red Sox fan and
growing up in the in the 90s and early
2000s we truly never believed that I'd
never thought you'd won right and and
then once it's broken of course you can
reel off yeah you know for more in the
next ten years or whatever but
yeah with when it comes to the curse of
the Bambino you don't realize it's a
curse for the first 15 20 years it only
becomes the curse of the Bambino in
retrospect like 2530 years long sample
size - yes oh it started the same year
because if the Giants don't win for the
next 4 or 5 years that's just luck of
the draw anyone can not win for 5 10
years in a row right so only when the
next generation is coming up they're
gonna look back at this era and be like
oh this was the curse of the Beckham B
no because I will also say the worst
possible case for Giants fans is well
how can we evaluate if Eli's actually
that bad because the wide receiving core
was so depleted hmm are they like they
have been able to make excuses for Eli
for the last five years the offensive
line isn't where it needs to be they
never had our running back now changes
in the OC well how can Li play all of
his wide receivers are hurt I'm just
saying Giants fans I'm very worried that
this could extend the Eli window now
Daniel Jones is the future at the same
point are they gonna go do we really
want to throw our rookie into a
situation with no wide receivers that's
exactly what you want to do I just I'm
just worried that the is the curse of
Becca and B no really extending Eli even
more is that part of the curse well I
mean if that's entirely possible that
Beckham leaving like people are gonna
think this offense would have been
trashed no matter who you put in there
so you might as well respect to get
across two rings the fact is they
haven't won a Super Bowl since 2011 I
believe was the 11 season right so it's
not like they've been lighting it up
year after year making the you know NFC
championship even the every year and
then Beckham leaves and all of a sudden
everything falls to crap so you can't
quite blame everything on one guy I just
as someone that has lived in this city
now for five and a half years and I've
heard the talk-show hosts in the
newspapers blame everything on Odell I
personally am and somewhat relieved that
they're going to experience a post Odell
issue mm-hmm because I think he was not
the issue here
and so I'm secretly hope not secretly
I'm very publicly hoping that there's a
curse so you know how it works with
fandom right
there they're just gonna take whatever
happens and they're gonna say oh it's
better for the team they're gonna
convince themselves of that it's that
cognitive yes and I don't think they are
like you think they're just gonna sit in
the room and cry about Odell for tonight
is a very intimate relationship with
Giants fans yes and there is a sadness
right now when they see highlights of
Odell it makes them feel sad he was the
star he was the guy he was the one that
the little kids bought jerseys of and
they had moved on and I think it's been
a weirdly really were a process now we
got a chance to interview in Tahoe mr.
Jordy Nelson this is not the longest of
interviews but it was very enlightening
for me he talked about Aaron Rodgers we
got a lot of insight there but I think
the thing that you'll appreciate the
most is him talking about why he loved
going to the Raiders because of the
perspective that it gave and after this
interview I'm gonna get into why it's
the opposite for AJ Green so here's my
conversation with Jordy Nelson yeah this
is a one-minute interview first of all
how are you this is my first year here
in Tahoe your first year - yes
absolutely
how you feeling is this your first year
as a retired man - yes yes it will be
hopefully official here in about a month
when we headed back up the greasy weird
bro it's not I think it will become
August September but right now it feels
really nice No thank you lady camp Soho
because that's the part where you're a
vet where you're like okay I mean we're
there two weeks out of training camp and
the last thing that's crossed my mind is
going to it so I think this fall will be
a little different but I look forward to
being home with the family back in
Kansas just relaxing I've always wanted
this when you have your career with the
team and you share that relationship
with the players and the fans and they
want you to do that one day contract at
the end the fans or so what does that
like to know that the love is just so
strong it's overwhelming I mean I don't
you know is another thing to do I think
and a lot of people do it but then I've
talked to some people some people in
organizations some people those fans in
the area and they're like oh yeah we're
so jacked that you're coming back we're
happy for our blah blah blah so it
really makes you understand why they do
it and it was
you know I'm very appreciative of Mark
Murphy gave me a call and gave me that
option to come back and do that and look
forward to doing it not you what's it
like to be a great wide receiver that
doesn't play in the slot that much right
come on oh I remember do when you're at
Kansas State and you burn the [ __ ] out
of a keep to leave at Kansas and I was
like people need to stop sleeping on
this it was fun I enjoyed all 11 years
of it in and out it was fun to have some
different conversations but we enjoyed
it it no we there's not one thing that
we you know regret of any decision we
made or any experience that we had very
fortunately some win a championship
it's been 10 years in Green Bay man and
at the same time honestly very fortunate
to get released and experienced that and
not have this like perfect world yeah oh
the NFL is so perfect go play 1012 years
in one spot and everything so we kind of
opened your eyes I'll add you to see
what some people go through every year
every two years Wow move around so you
don't want it to happen but it was great
to see that to be honest with you I know
you have to leave so can I ask you one
last question on this podcast we say
Aaron Rodgers the greatest quarterback
we've ever seen Pat mahomes is close
okay but I'm curious when you kind of
experienced Aaron was there a story or
the first time when you went this guy is
just different in his ability was there
like a like an oh [ __ ] moment plenty of
those but to me it's his mind when he
can pull things back from years before
drop out yeah then we did that in game
15 in 2007 verse the Vikings and that
not every guy can do though it's a whole
nother level and the best part about it
was it challenged you to get to that
level Wow you try to get on that same
page to be able to form the chemistry
that we had and push you to the next
level we knew here people questioned
that guy and how he is as a teammate
like what's your response to that are
you laugh and it's a joke so to me those
people I don't know I don't need to get
involved in it because I say [ __ ] those
people like I'll say that but a lot of
it I mean but I hear like the way that
you're looking at challenges you like I
said to get on his level
and it's very hard to get there and I'm
not saying I did but mentally I wanted
to be there yeah and then I think that's
why we had the success we did I
appreciate you bro Jordy Nelson's got a
run out of here time to go
hopefully not hit people yeah and uh
congratulations on reaching the next
stage of your life did appreciate it now
I get it hopefully play golf yeah
so what Jordy said was that he was glad
to go to the Raiders and it's kind of a
shot at the Raiders because it made him
realize that the situation he had been
with the Packers was the perfect
situation it's nice that he was that he
was able to realize that because
sometimes you don't know what you have
at a certain job any job anyone that's
out there at a great company you don't
know that until you go to a place that's
not as great and it's still and that's
the shot at the Raiders is him realizing
that the rest of the NFL is sometimes a
[ __ ] and he got that experience
with Jon Gruden in the Raiders so it's a
little bit of a shot but at the same
point it makes you appreciate and then
when I see what happened to AJ green and
the fact that he got carted off and I'm
gonna say it part of the reason is the
cincinnati bengals were trying to honor
the NFL 100 so they held a practice at
welcome Stadium and Dayton Ohio and
fellow wide receiver Tyler Boyd said the
turf was terrible and that he saw rocks
and pebbles on the turf and then your
star wide receiver tears a ligament in
his left ankle and is likely out six to
eight weeks which means he's going to be
recovering with an ankle injury at about
around week four or week five so who
knows when he's gonna be a hundred
percent right and I think about how
Jordy Nelson didn't know he was in the
perfect situation his whole career and
then realized that some teams are a
[ __ ] and here's AJ green one of
the best wide receivers physically that
has ever played in the NFL I am
constantly amazed at when I see
intervener back interviews and they go
man I didn't realize how good AJ Green
was until I got on the field he came in
the same year as Julio Jones Julio Jones
has had Matt Ryan the whole time right
Julio Jones has had offensive
coordinators like Kyle Shanahan
and still AJ Green is right up there
with them statistically pretty much
head-to-head that entire run with Andy
Dalton and Marvin Lewis and Mike Brown
as his owner GM one of the cheapest
franchises and I think about how AJ
Green doesn't even know what good is AJ
Green's on the opposite AJ Green star
offensive coordinator was Hugh Jackson
now we look back and we know what Hugh
Jackson is Hugh Jackson won one game in
two years he couldn't get the offense
rolling and that was the star was he the
store or was it because they had AJ
Green at Mohamed Sanu and all these guys
and a good offensive line and like they
had Jeremy hill and they had Giovanni
Bernard and they had Tyler Eifert like
AJ Green doesn't even know what good is
AJ Green is one of these guys that when
he's up for the Hall of Fame will have
never tasted what these other guys have
been able to taste unless his next
contract he gets on some other contender
but he's my number one pick member we
talked about the loaner system in yes
in Europe I want AJ Green to experience
like one year with the Patriot explain
to me why the Patriots can't give let's
say you know a 2020 second-round pick to
the Bengals in exchange for eight weeks
of AJ Green from December to January
it'll be amazing it'll be amazing we'll
just see what he can do
I just AJ Green there are so many guys
like I worried about like Vince Carter
was kind of that guy for a while in the
Raptors and there's so many cross sport
guys that have been on one team their
whole career like that's how I feel
about Mike Trout like the angels aren't
doing [ __ ] and he's just these amazing
years year after year and they're never
gonna do anything now we're in like the
ninth year it keeps the Krauts like 21
years old he's now in his ninth year and
has never tasted any form of sustained
success replay off at Batson and and I
think about this with Calvin Johnson and
those years in the Lions and how they
weren't able to build everything but I
feel so bad for AJ Green and it makes me
sad
and I would say the Bengals right now
are up there with the dolphins for
likely to be first pick in the draft
mm-hmm I just and I feel bad for Zack
Taylor you know I mean here's this
rookie coach coming in that I don't have
high hopes for the bay I just feel bad
for AJ Green it makes me sad so but we
know the NFL is crazy and when it comes
to these divisional bets right everyone
if you would if you talked to a thousand
NFL fans of who you have checked the end
of the AFC North would one of them pick
the Bengals no because they're like 40
plus 4500 in Vegas right now or
something like that
throw down 10 bucks I don't know
something crazy could happen because
here's here's my main thing is the
reason this is my fear about the Bengals
of all of the Sean McVeigh friends that
were hired so that includes a Kliff
Kingsbury in Arizona that includes who
was the other guy that got hired Matt
Lafleur going to Green Bay the guy with
the least experience was Zach Taylor and
we saw this with the Seattle defense as
that spread through the NFL as all the
teams see it a lot they learn what the
beaters are they learn what the like
they studied Kyle Shanahan and that
helps them with Zach Taylor Zach has the
least amount of ammunition because he's
he was a quarterbacks coach so he will
be the one that everyone's ready for but
he doesn't have the answers to their
answers plus he has Andy Dalton plus
their offensive line is injured plus
they don't have AJ Green the bengals
right now are really shaping up to be
the team that they might be the first
pick in the draft they might be they
might be they might also go 9 and 7
all right so we do have three pretty big
whoa big off seasons which means it's
time Nickolas to play that beautiful
noise
[Music]
big offseason and it looks like one that
we warned people about last week is
starting to really come into full effect
yeah this is happening a lot more I feel
like you mentioned something on the
podcast and then like within 24 hours
there's some real news that either
resolves it or furthers the story or
something this [ __ ] is very predictable
should we just jump in with number one
well I think the Trent Williams just
update is kind of interesting yeah so
train Williams the holdout update Morgan
Moses wore a trim williams jersey to a
press conference which i think what's
interesting is the jason lock in for a
tweet really started everything he
tweeted as I reported months ago the
relationship between Trent Williams and
the skins is totally fractured he
doesn't trust Bruce Allen or the medical
team there and made it known long ago he
does not intend to play for them again
now Washington has come out and said
that part is not true Morgan Moses also
said that he expects Trent Williams back
but teammates always say that when they
think a deals gonna get done I don't
know if Trent Williams wants more
guaranteed money but as we talked about
on last week's show this is when there
is no trust with a GM and so much more
than money it's so much more than money
but we're I think gonna get with Trent
Williams something very similar to the
NFL ref holdout that happened the
perfect storm of the NFL ref holdout was
there were a lot of calls being missed
on the field to fail merrier and then
there was the failed Mary which you need
for leverage in anything a perfect
representation of an issue to prove that
you need it so when the Seattle Green
Bay game came down to one refs hands up
and one refs hands going side to side
the funniest people Graham that's an
issue fix it and then they came back
very ceremoniously with the hat tip at
the Thursday Night Football game I
believe that Trent Williams if he is
real about this is going to have that
situation probably in week one because
right now the backup is Eric flowers
that sound you hear is a 33% laughing
because they realize what I'm talking
about I'm pretty sure Washington plays
the Eagles in week one if Case Keenum
who I'm betting as the starter get
sacked multiple times on Eric flowers
side
Trent Williams is gonna have so much
leverage because it's Eric flowers like
there is no left tackle in this league
that's more of a punchline than Eric
flowers right incredibly talented but
he's a turnstile and you saw him twice a
year with the Giants I'm just saying
right now that if Trent Williams is
patient his holdout I know he doesn't
want to do it like nobody wants to miss
games but let Eric flowers get out there
maybe it happens in a preseason game
I'm just saying Trent take your time man
because the best proof of how good you
are it's gonna happen in weeks one and
two
yeah maybe Trent Williams the move for
him is just to go to his agent and be
like look I need you to sign Eric
flowers in the next couple weeks and
tell him to just let a couple guys
through like sunshine asked you to and
Remember the Titans yeah just let him
through just let him through a mess
because you don't even have to have all
right now let's get to the big woes all
right Mike Daniels how about that did
you see that 13 teams called him mmm and
he ended up picking the Detroit Lions
because of Matt Patricia unbelievable
quote he's a genius he really is he
understands the game of football first
of all very glad to know that the head
coach of an NFL team is the game of
football you're understanding the whoas
quote he knows what it takes to be able
to play for a coach like that it means
everything I think when you look at the
Detroit defensive line right now it's
looking pretty special tre flowers they
sign the offseason now they have Mike
Daniels a Sean Robinson the high draft
picked out of Alabama that's really been
coming on to Sean hand who had an
amazing rookie year last year
snacks Harrison now can come in off the
bench if you want oh croire who they got
from the Giants last year and had eight
sacks if you know the Patriots defense
they want the big ugly's up front and
now they got a guy that Patricia
definitely knows and Trey flowers Chad
and if they have one shut down corner
they can be special like you guys were
with Darrelle Revis back in the day they
have that in darius ley jr. I think the
Lions I look at how they were last year
they were the team that really made the
blueprint on how to slow down the Rams
and if it wasn't for too late forgetful
touchdowns by the Rams they would have
only had like 16 points in that game
they had a great game plan to start the
year against the Jets when they kind of
had that that first play where they pick
six on Sam darn 'old but the Lions held
the Packers scoreless at the end of the
year but I look at it like this the whoa
here is Patricia for the last year and a
half we've been talking about the things
that he's not being great at he's been
not great at dealing with the media
having the argument with the guy that
was styling just loud yeah we were not
great with him saying weird [ __ ] about
practicing outside and inside and how's
it gonna work people have been
questioning them their work there were
big issues that came out last year about
how he was trying to get people to run
they didn't want to but when you have a
Pro Bowler in your division that faces
you twice a year and he chose you when
Adam Schefter reported that Mike Daniels
wanted to go to a Super Bowl contender
and you're not gonna find one analyst
that's gonna say the Detroit Lions are
going to the Super Bowl now I think the
NFC North is the most up for grabs
division and I think if the Lions are
fourth and you said picking them I'd say
I understand what you're talking about
big offensive line great D line all that
but for a guy to face twice a year to
look over at what the defense is doing
every time and then that guy go he's a
genius I have not heard Patricia called
a genius yet I have heard people
question as genius and say how much was
Belichick but to me this is a ringing
endorsement that wakes me up it's a real
woe for me mm-hmm
because maybe maybe we're sleeping on
the Lions a little bit I respect the
fact that they finally moved on from
Theo Riddick and maybe it's gonna be
carry on Johnson's team I'm not gonna
get too hyped but I'm paying attention
to the Lions because of Mike Daniels
right
no I like this yeah you you learn a lot
as you said divisional rivals they know
a lot about their opponents right like I
as a Patriots fan just know a lot more
about the coaching staff of the Jets and
the Dolphins that's what about you know
some random team on the west coast and
when you're when you're in those of it
especially the NFC North those those
teams are thinking about each other 24/7
365 they're learning from each other
they're copying each other's playbook
slay each other on Thanksgiving or the
Bears and Packers have the longest
rivalry in all of sports yoghurts and
they're truly all in the same area but
come on the little edge yeah they're
right there they're all with the driving
distance essentially so maybe that's
part of the reason maybe Mike Daniels
just like you know wanted to be able to
commute from Milwaukee to Detroit it's
like affordable ubers but just got my
attention so free agent decisions the
first whoa yeah
next up rookie buzz Paris Campbell has
in my mind become the whoa Rookie of the
Year already Wow and what I mean ready
to make that stake that claim what I
mean though is is as buzz goes around I
start to see where people gravitate to
and this first weekend was the Paris
Campbell whoa rook Heath like he won
Offensive Rookie of the Year this past
weekend is what it felt like the Oprah
special sure yeah yeah
so Frank Reich quote from Frank Reich
the two plays he made in the red zone
today weren't hybrid gadgets slot
receiver type plays they were legit NFL
I'm gonna be a stud receiver plays Wow
ran two phenomenal routes made two big
plays in the red zone everything we've
seen so far has been a very positive
sign that's Frank Reich when I say whoa
remember I survey the NFL landscape at
all times
Friday there was a huge fantasy
analytics push behind Paris Campbell
where people were talking in dynasty
leagues about how he's the guy to target
on the Colts team because of the
packages they use and he fits perfectly
then Saturday at camp he does this Frank
Reich starts blowing up and think about
it it's the first week of training camp
all of the national reporters are going
around and they're going to go to the
camps of contenders first so a lot of
those national reporters were in Indy
and they watch that performance
life this is why I'm not a huge fan of
going to training camps you go to a
training camp you see Paris Campbell
make all the best plays and then when
you go into the season you're basing
your entire predictions on Paris
Campbell off of one practice mhm the
bias builds where I'd rather almost see
nobody follow the trusted reporters that
I know are there every practice and pay
attention to the whole thing I know this
is counter that a lot of people say you
got to be out there and see it gonna be
very honest but where you're like super
spicy supernova hot takes gonna come
from if you can't just guess based on
two plays that you watched exactly right
like I always tell the story me and Sims
went to Raiders camp one time and we go
over and watch it Amari Cooper and he's
Dustin people sure and Simpson look at
me going this is incredible and we did a
podcast later and he was like I tell you
what man this Amari Cooper kid is
special he's really amazing and I
admitted to Sims two and a half years
later that I didn't realize that what he
was doing was special out there then I
just saw a guy making catches like oh
that's cool and seems like his footwork
is insane you need to know what you
don't know the intricacies of the game I
don't have down and I'm very willing to
admit that that's why I trust on people
that I trust to evaluate the game so for
me it's AI and I'm gonna be very honest
I'm gonna tell you that I believe most
of the national reporters that are going
around and our watch in practice have no
[ __ ] idea see you're mine I'm telling
you that most reporters do not
understand what they're doing I would
sit there and I'd watch because this is
what happens Pro eight reporters will
sit to each other on the sidelines and
they're all watching and then a guy
makes a catch and they go he's really
good I don't care about the catches you
know what I care about who's getting
first team reps mm because that's
showing me who the coach wants to put in
but from like a catch being great or
like the coach telling me that this guy
is really showing up that might be
motivation I'm not taking that coach's
word for it it's just a lot of [ __ ]
this is a big Jackie McMullen thing who
is to me one of the goat reporters of
all time Boston Globe and although yeah
and just been covering the NBA for
decades she was talking about how don't
focus on how many
they scored how many assists they got
focus on what assignments the coach is
giving them yes oh look at that you know
this rookie is out there in the fourth
quarter of a close game Kobe right like
that's the assignment he's getting now
whether he succeeded or not that can be
factored in later but let's look at this
young guy and say the coach who's around
this guy more than you are as a reporter
he's giving this person this elevated
assignment that matters more this is
what we always used talked about with
Jabril Peppers Jabril Peppers would be
played 30 yards off the line of
scrimmage and in a way hidden on the
defense if people say oh but look at the
interceptions it's like the coaches do
not want to put him in one-on-one
situation right that's the true feeling
about your bell peppers so that's when
you see like highlights and all that
stuff they're just highlights I wish
every beat reporter out there would just
track snaps and reps with the first
teams because that's the information
that we can glean the rest of it is a
day-to-day basis and a lot of it's
[ __ ] so that's my long take there
now I get moving on to well number three
yes into the world of bears kickers
which has been a sassy world the last
couple of months the best thing is
quarterback controversies yeah but we
don't really have that there's only one
team where we have that right now in
dolphins and that's Josh Rosen versus
Ryan Fitzpatrick but the Bears you'll
consider the Redskins to be a little bit
controversial yeah you know what yes I
just feel so convinced that they're not
gonna play Haskins right away okay yeah
it's just it's set we got case we're
good well when it's a rookie like with
Daniel Jones you're like whenever they
they've already probably circled on the
schedule when they want to bring them in
mm-hmm and so it's it doesn't feel like
a real battle to me what's the word one
level down cuz QB controversy to me is
like oh [ __ ] do we choose Brady or
Bledsoe oh my god that's a controversy
what's one level down from the injury a
QB quandary
okay the q.q I like this the QB quandary
there's a couple of Tears kicker battle
that's a battle feels like a quarterback
battle because of how their season ended
because of how they've treated it thus
far the fact that Matt Nagy has been
replaying the double doink
constantly the fact that they're they're
openly having kickoffs at a silent E
practice really like weird silent but I
try out it went up a notch this week
yeah have I
some news for you people following the
kicker quandary is out there bears
kicker Elliott Frey had made six of
seven field goals Saturday when he
insisted that he try a 60 yarder he
split the uprights he banged it through
Eddie Bernero had drilled six of seven
on Sunday when it was time for what Matt
naggy called quote dealer's choice
coaches asked Panero if he wanted to try
a 60 yard or the way Frey had quote I
was like nah you guys hit 60 yesterday
Panera said we're gonna 63 today hey
Pinero made the 63 yard kick with
distance to spare the crowd of 8,000 813
chanted his name at all of it Nazarene
University
apparently they said that the explosion
of the cheer Bears players were saying
it rivaled being in Soldier so think
about this this is why it's awesome
I didn't know that I didn't even know
who was trying not to be the kicker
before I saw this Elliot Frey and Eddie
Panero these are the two guys going for
the kicks usually with the kicker
battles it's kept secret everything is
coming out about this kicker battle so
Frey goes out there and bangs a 60 and
Saturday you know he went home called
his family up this gesture to see yeah
yeah practices mine then the next day
Panero comes in and Nagy probably and
far the whole team was like what do you
want to kick [ __ ] said let me go
63 dude banged it in I think what we
should do I'm thinking this right now do
you want to be I want to give you first
pick do you want to be an Elliott fry
guy or an Eddie Panero guy I want to go
ed Eddie Panero cuz he sounds like a
dude from Jersey Eddie panera oh you
know old Eddie Panero old gesture and
then I'm gonna be a fry guy your Fraga
Elliott fry so what we're gonna do is is
as stories come out throughout camp I'm
gonna try and find the positive Elliott
Fry's stories along the negative Panero
stories and your team at a Panera
hashtag team Panera joined Manero and
I'm team fry and by the way do you know
much about any of these go [ __ ]
nothing
okay I don't know anything about these
guys I'm gonna I really want to get
emotionally invested into the Bears
kick-off yeah so I'm going with Elliott
in the span of the last 12 seconds while
you made up this game I'm now super
emotionally invested in the future
Pinero like if eddie Venera gets it off
of 160 i'm picking up in fantasy how
about that third round third-round pick
and fantasy penny Panero all right we
are now fully invested in the Bears
kickers all right so the other video
interview that we had is with Kyle
Rudolph really good conversation where
he talked about the tight ends in the
league Kelsey and and Ernst and what he
takes from those guys how this offense
for the Vikings got comfortable at the
end of the year with Stefanski the new
OC and Kurt cousins but I think what's
really cool is the Anthony bar story the
Anthony bar signing with the Jets and
coming back Kyle Rudolph has the same
agent and let's just say he woke up
surprised the next day so here's my
interview with Kyle Rudolph that's when
you know you're official with you got
one of those yeah you also know you're
official when you sign on the dotted
line with a brand new contract thank you
I like to give my listeners inside the
mind of what you guys go through because
they need to realize sometimes that
you're human yeah absolutely when my
contracts in a contract year it's all I
can think about and then when you sign
it it's like freedom absolutely are you
in that mode now yeah and you know going
through this contract negotiation was
different than say even my rookie
contract or you know my second contract
that I signed in Minnesota now I've been
there for eight years and I wanted to
stay in Minnesota and they wanted to
keep me in Minnesota so it was more a
matter of just that's a yeah how do we
work out the financial situation given
our team's tough cap and cash deal so
you know I think it's more stressful on
our families you know my wife worrying
about you know our kids are enrolled in
preschool more in Minnesota
we're gonna have to change that but it
really never came to a point where we
ever thought we'd play anywhere else in
Minnesota and like I said I had all the
faith in my team personally my agents
yeah and the Vikings as well that they
would get something done I know you Ohio
guys have a lot of pride you are you
like kind of becoming a Minnesota guy
now
souta's definitely home for us now
that's awesome I'll always have that
hometown Cincinnati Ohio fahrrad but
Minneapolis and the twin cities are our
home for us now and you know for the
rest of our lives no matter where
football takes us I was talking to you
on the way over here about Kelsey
another Cincinnati guy you two Kittel
who else am I missing right now that's
been perfect like where are we right now
the tight end position the NFL it's a
fun time to be a tight end in the
service because you know we feel like
our position allows you to kind of
dictate what you want to do on offense
and quite honestly if you get more than
one tight end on the field and you can
create mismatches and kind of dictate
the tempo of the game dictate whether
it's run or pass and it makes you
unpredictable yeah in our league
defenses do such a good job of studying
and preparing and if you can just gain a
little bit of an edge and be
multiplicity right a little 21 a little
as well a little bit yeah when how when
did you see Kirk get comfortable last
year what week do you think it really
kind of turned well you know it was
interesting because Kirk came out of the
gates you know the first four weeks of
the year he was on fire that throw
against Green Bay in the quarter yeah
there's one of the best throws of the
entire season yeah under pressure and
you know I don't know if it was the
drive after that or the drive before
that I don't remember the sequence but
he threw a post Stefan for an 80 yard
touchdown that was on the money too and
you know we were down 20 points in the
fourth quarter
Devin came back tied it had a chance to
win in overtime and you know
unfortunately just ended in a tie but it
he came out on fire last season and you
know I think our lack of success kind of
overshadowed his success as a
quarterback last you see how they just
cheered for Charles Barkley love Chuck I
got to know Chuck earlier this offseason
I played in a celebrity basketball game
and I was on his team he was so Chuck is
this podcast official sports uncle he's
accepted that yeah so whenever we need a
little advice or drink and he was talk
to me about women and stuff he's the
sport uncle I love that's awesome
with Curt they'll go to new year - are
we expecting the offense and also a
Stefanski
because that offense completely changed
gears when he came in
a healthy Dalvin cook hmm kind of feel
like you guys are getting slept on a
little bit yeah but that's okay you know
like that in you know rightfully so we
didn't perform on offense last year our
defense played really well for most of
the year special teams gave us a chance
and you know we didn't execute on third
down we didn't score as many touchdowns
in the red zone is we're accustomed to
shore and but with Kevin's too fancy
taking over also the addition of Gary
Kubiak or entering our offense he brings
a lot of championship experience to our
offense I have two hard-hitting
questions for you first one's actually
serious second one not so much with the
Anthony Barr thing where were you
because I was like fascinated by it what
was it like to as a teammate to
experience I was actually anything I
have the same agent athletes Hearst in
Southern California and I was in their
office at the time and you know his
agent would come out of his offense
office and it was you know this deal is
closed yeah and it was like I'm on the
phone he wants to go back to Minnesota
and it was back and forth limbo limbo
and then when I left the office that day
he had agreed on a deal and then I woke
up the next morning you know glad we got
him back yeah what did you like did you
already congrat cuz you're gonna
congratulate he goes to the Jets too but
I know I just sent them a text and told
him congratulations and you know it's
that's what you work for you you work
your whole career to get yourself in a
position where you're set for life
financially your family set for life yes
and he was able to do that and then to
find out that he was going to take less
money to come back to Minnesota because
of the culture that was pretty cool
that's got to feel good no doubt and I
think that's one of the things that we
have and one of the reasons I think
we'll separate ourselves from other
teams in this league it's the culture
that we have in our locker room you know
for myself personally I had no desires
of trying to get the free agency and
going somewhere else and possibly making
more money I wanted to stay in Minnesota
it's about the culture there it's about
when in the first championship in
Minnesota even the way you saved
Minnesota you're picking it up always
come on I did rankings recently this is
my last hard-hitting question of if I
were a ranked quarterbacks and their
ability to use the grill you need 1
through 32
one I had drew brees I did deep dives
and everyone's social yeah two was
Stafford I've seen these guys through
the grill
I had Kirk Cousins last mm-hmm because
there's been some pictures that have
come out these last few years using
tinfoil on the grill
he had one where it looked like there
was no seasoning at all I just need to
know if I'm on base here right now my
off base I mean have you ever seen her
cousins grilled I have not
it's hard to argue with that evidence
you know if you're putting the tinfoil
down and the no seasoning but I feel
like now as a father of two that's kind
of your responsibility is to not always
to get better I'd get better at the
grill I just want to work with Kirk I
want to improve this part of his game we
will all check in we'll see maybe this
summer before we go to camp a little
barbecue salt pepper a little garlic you
know like a little seasoning on I got a
burger seasoning for you one of my
former teammates Chad Greenway taught me
this so I hope you're packing the
burgers you know obviously you'd never
just throw the three package burgers on
a dress so we're so sorry okay
the Chipotle Tabasco oh and then some
salt and pepper mix it all up and then
throw that on the grill give it a try
and there it is Rudolph I'm gonna put
you number one a favor do that I
appreciate you thanks again to Kyle
Rudolph I hit that [ __ ] up on
Twitter seems like six eleven by the way
imposing gentlemen but nice as hell him
and Kelsey when you see them you go I
understand why you can block and receive
sure because you guys are practically
offensive linemen except you're you have
like 5% body and you know that if he
wanted to turn into an offensive lineman
just give him like three months of the
right different kinds of workouts and
meals and he'd be there oh it's
unbelievable so the float tank so we
have not talked about this yeah I want
to hear any people do not know what it
is I was listening to my guys podcast
his name's Alex Mitchell Hart you can
listen to his podcast called Mitchell
shares and I've known this guy
went to college with him and he's really
been one of my Sherpas through like
meditation and stuff like that hole sent
me books and then I'll buy the book and
end up reading it like that's how atomic
habits I saw a post about his Instagram
stories like I'm gonna check this out
sure but he has done float tanks like 70
times Wow and I was like alright I want
to try it and float tanks is complete
dark if your eyes are closed or your
eyes are open it's the same thing that's
crazy experience like blindness is
interesting you are in a huge tub with a
thousand pounds of epson salt that's how
concentrated is like the Dead Sea so
when you lay on it you legitimately
float like it's impossible for you to
touch the bottom and it's shallow and
also when you fully relax you're ahead
when it goes underwater your ears go
under see you can't see you're not
feeling you're not touching anything and
when your ears are underwater you really
hear your heartbeat move so you are you
feel like you're in outer space mm-hmm
now the only thing that was weird about
my experience was when I went onto Yelp
to find the best float tanks this guy
popped up and it seemed like a very
official place and then I realized it
was a guy's apartment really so I did it
in a dudes apartment no way here in
Manhattan here on 23rd that's crazy so
and it's this dude that looks like he
might be 90 might be 40 I don't know
incredible head of hair and books as far
as the eye could see
perfect feng shui he had all these
pencil drawings of like Albert Einstein
that he's drawn and stuff like this is a
man that float tanks like three hours at
a time no way okay so you just
would you like Buzz up to his assignment
I didn't tell you about this is
fascinating you did not tell me this I
assume you went to a facility in Queens
that you know where they do this I
texted my fiance right beforehand I said
if I die yeah this is where I am this is
exactly where I am and and I'm going to
talk about this on on Mitch's podcast
more in depth too but
yeah I got buzzed up and then he met me
and I I had to call him the day before
to set it up and he the reason I felt
comfortable was I read an article he's
mentioned in like every article he's
been doing it for over 30 years so he's
seen all of the fads come and go and
he's just kept doing it huh because he
wants to do it but the reason I felt
comfortable was he purposely made it
difficult for people especially
Millennials to come like you have to
talk to him on the phone because he
doesn't want it to be some transactional
service where people just come up he
does one [ __ ] casuals and so in a
weird way I appreciated it so I buzz up
there and he spent time on the first one
explaining to me how I'm gonna do it
yeah and then he put up a divider and
then I took a shower in that apartment
uh-huh
and everything's professional like it
looks like he's got all the the stuff of
course of course before that and and so
then I walked over and I go into a room
and I closed the door and then I open a
sliding door and I get in so it's
completely noise proof in there and I
get in and I lay down and I'm naked
Wow and the first five minutes were me
getting over the field that he was at
fear was gonna walk in and like like
kill me sure and then once I got over
that it was amazing this is crazy I mean
how big is the tub it's like the size of
a bedroom it's that long tub that's like
four feet wide okay and so what you do
is you kind of push your outside of your
hands on the outside to create a stable
thing and you get in as calm as you can
and then you turn the light off and you
realize you're in pitch black and then
you slowly release your hands and I'm
just gonna say that when I let my head
go all the way back which is you don't
even realize like he was telling me that
he has Navy SEALs that come in and
they're just so trained to not go
underwater that once you really go back
and you're just weightless I it felt
like I was spinning in outer space
I also simultaneously knew that my body
was the same and I left and I didn't use
my phone for like an hour or two and I
have never felt more connected dude like
I try to meditate but that was like
cramming ten meditation sessions into an
hour are you gonna go back yeah I think
so
we finger I don't know it's his house
like I like he was like you got very
lucky one of my normals cancelled and I
was like I don't know if this is you
upselling me or ever but like I wouldn't
had lunch with my cousin afterwards and
I was just dropping Jim's like like are
like my coffee was not high when I said
it does not matter it is still coffee
and I was like what the [ __ ] what are
these words coming out of my brain but
it just it was really really good
it was really special is there some sort
of safe word because I'm sure some
people freaked out after three minutes
you just stand up oh right okay sure
yeah but like what if you can't find the
light switch or like do people freak out
right next to your hands I'm just
thinking like somebody freaks out I so
what's interesting is is like after I
got done I walked out and I go back I
take another shower but you don't want
to wash too much cuz you kind of want
the salt there cuz it's great for your
body addicts well it's the same with the
dead said I went to the gym the day
before and then after that I was like
not sore at all like it felt very
therapeutic and then I go out to his
living room and there's a cool glass of
herbal green tea that he made and then
we talked for like 10 minutes nice and I
found myself my ego wanted to be like so
do people get freaked out but mine was
like it's very interesting when it feels
like you're falling and then he would
share his experiences and then someone
buzzed and he was like my next person's
here I was like I gotta go
it was dope this is great so I thought
about what is one meaningful thing that
I want to leave because I think a lot of
you guys reached out to me after the
last podcast when I kind of went on that
rant about putting your fears to paper
and I think I want to challenge myself
to have one little nugget that I want to
impart and I think one thing that I took
from the whole experience that I would
want to give to you guys is it's
actually harder to get upset and what I
mean in that sentence is as we go
through our days all the time there will
be things that pop up where you will
have a decision which is to get upset
about
or to just let it wash over and it's
actually more effort to get upset now it
seems easier to get angry it seems
easier to channel your ego and if in
burr does something that I don't like to
look at him and to go no but really it
takes more effort it's so much easier to
just go okay and then move on and what I
would say to everyone is when you're in
if you're in New York City and then
there's some stuff happen in the subway
it's okay just move away from it if you
have someone that you work with that
maybe frustrates you it's okay it's
gonna eventually get done and if if your
favorite team or family or someone else
disappoint you it's okay so I know that
you guys got a lot of stress going on
you guys hit me up on the dm's about
like [ __ ] that's going on in your life
just remember that we're here for a long
[ __ ] time and it takes more effort to
get angry than it does to just get the
[ __ ] done so that's where I'm gonna say
I felt very in tune this weekend sounds
like it was dope Wow I really enjoy this
I want you to light a candle and an in
sent and say with me the new side of
left go I like this oh it's gonna last
like a day sure yeah yeah alright so
coming up later this week I have a few
interviews so I haven't decided which
one to go but Tuesday 5 p.m. that is the
cutoff for the let's [ __ ] go League
which I'm gonna occasionally call it
that so make sure you sign up let's see
if we can go over 800 we're literally
like 794 the last time I checked and
we're gonna continue the whoa big
offseason for Nick back there running
the show for Engler holds it down
I am the lef koe man and we will holler
at y'all soon can't wait to kick you
guys ass in fantasy
[Music]